right so in the previous video we looked
at how we can build an operator ISM that
can switch between multiple processes to
create the illusion that they're running
at the same time and we saw with the
demo we've got here we had this model
that enabled us to conceive how we had
different processes running at the same
time so we always have one that's
running and we can have other processes
or the programs that are either blocked
waiting for something to happen from the
operating system play waiting for user
input or network IO or disk IO or
something and we can have others that
are ready to run but are just waiting if
you want to see other video we can see
that we can then switch the ones that
are running to be runnable and so on so
that we can then get another one running
and if we do that fast enough we do it
say every two hundredth of a second we
can give the illusion that these
processes are all running at the same
time and occasionally they become
unblocked and they can then be ready to
be run of all until one of them finishes
puts a comment on the previous video
saying would it be possible to go
directly from create to runnable yes in
fact that's probably what you do if you
look at the source code for a unix a
then yet when the price is created it
does end up in runnable but it's put in
a position so the next time you context
switch which you won't get a look at
today it will become running and so on
we said when we looked at this video
that there's three things we need we
need this model so we know how we're
going to switch them and which ones we
can switch it on we need a way of
knowing which process we're going to
move from run a ball to running at which
point in time and the final thing we
need is some physical way that we can
make the CPU stop running one program
and then start running the other that's
what we're gonna look at today it's
called what's called context switching
because we're switching from the context
which one programs running to switching
to the context that another program is
running so to understand how context
switching works we need to think about
how our CPU excuse program so let's
actually have a look at a very simple
program I'm going to write it using our
machine code because the context
switching does happen at the machine
code level doesn't happen a higher-up as
we use a compiler the high-level
language so let's think about a very
simple program that is going to load in
a string I'm going to use our machine
code for this example so we're gonna
load in the address
I was string into our zero so let's call
this H string and then we're going to
print it out and I use a development
environment for developing our machine
code which is written to the University
of Manchester which allows me to call
the equivalent of the operating system
using swai 3 to print something out so
that's going to print something out and
we'll define H string up here to have a
hello world in it and then let's do
something else let's print out all the
numbers from 1 to 10 so we'll move into
R 1 the value of 0 and then we'll start
a loop we're gonna add 1 comma R 1 comma
1 we should move that into the register
R 0 and then we'll call another pseudo
operating system function to print out
an integer so we're adding 1 to the
valley we put it in there so because
from 0 to 1 we added 1 onto it with a
moving to another register and then we
call the operands
printed-out will then compare our value
in r1 with 10 and we'll branch if it's
less than 10 so branch if it's less than
10 to loop and then we'll print out
something else yeah so again we set our
zero to point to our string and we'll
call this I string if you want have a
better name that will call out so I 3
dot a lot and I'll be the rest of the
program so we've got a simple arm
machine code program it will just use
arm for the example could do exactly the
same while the x86 AMD 64 chip we could
have exactly the same or the 6 8000 ship
a 6502 it doesn't matter we're just
using our example so we've talked about
this before on computer file but the way
this program works is every time we
execute instruction somewhere inside the
CPU this was probably even worse to see
we have a set of registers r0 r1 r2 and
so on and these can just store a
temporary value so as we run through the
program this one says put the address of
8 string in our 0 so we work out what it
is and we want to value in there then we
call this and this calls off into our
pseudo operating system and we'll print
out whatever it is that it's doing so
it'll use that value and probably
manipulate new registers well then come
to the next line which moves the value
of 0 into there and then we come to the
next line which gets the value after the
register R 1 which is 0 adds 1 onto it
which is 1
yeah and then stores the result back in
r1 we're now at the next line which gets
the value r1 which is 1 and stores it
you know so it moves it into r0 we then
call us Y 4 which prints it out
then we come here we compare r1 which is
one with 10 it's less than so we go
around the loop and then we do the same
we get the value of r1 which is 1 we add
1 to it which is 2 and we update the
value to have now got 2 in our wall so
that's the model that our CPU runs the
program and to understand how context
switching is we need to remember that
this instruction only ever looks at the
value of r1 we're interested in this
yellow instruction here for it to work
the only thing it needs is the value
that's currently in our one we doesn't
care how that value got there it could
have got there because we've moved zero
into it here which is why I was the
first time or it could have got there
because we've added one into it
previously it doesn't make any
difference to the operation of that
instruction as long as the value of our
wand has the same value in then it'll do
exactly the same thing so if it has a
value 1 in it it will always add 1 and
become 2 it has a value of 0 and it will
always become 1 and that store 1 in it
so so it doesn't matter how it got there
and that is the key to understanding how
context switching works what happens
when we context switch is we have one
program running and it's executing lots
and lots of different code to make
things happen but at some point that
Prohm gets interrupted either because
it's called the operating system or
because there's an interrupt in the
computer which has hit the operating
system and the operating system says oK
you've had enough time on this I'm going
to switch to something else
and things we talked about briefly in
the previous video let's say we are here
we've got to this point in our program
we've got an interrupt happening here
and we're going to contact switch now
the operating system edit context which
is needs to make sure that when it comes
back here this Prohm continues as if
nothing had happened so just so that
we're can be absolutely clear on this so
and you say context switching this is
switching jelly babies in opera yeah so
this is switching from one program
running to the other program running so
we're going from this one to this one
and then back to this one as if nothing
had happened when this one had run so we
need to switch from this one so this is
the first one and we're going to star
one in this one so at this point we need
to store the state or the context of
this program so that we can then after
we've run this one switch it back to
running this program instead and this
can continue as if nothing had happened
and as we've seen the reason we can do
that is because as long as the values in
our registers have exactly the same
values and as long as the value in
memory have exactly the same values then
the program will continue to execute in
the same thing each of these
instructions only depends on the values
on the registers not how they got there
so all we need to do is make sure
whenever we switch from one probe
to another that we keep track of the
state of the program its context so that
when we come to load a different one we
can switch in it stage and it will carry
so how do we go about storing the state
of the program we need to store so the
things we store the value of the
registers and any other state that is
responsible for keeping the program
running now things in memory we can hide
quite easily modern operating systems
support virtual memory and so we can
just map one precedence memory out and
map another processor memory and so that
preserves the state of the memory very
easily the more involved part it comes
as storing the state of the registers
and still in the state of the CPU but
actually that ends up being relatively
straightforward what we do is we have a
process control block for each process
in the operating system and as part of
that we store the values of the
registers and a few other things in
there so if we start off by having a
look at our process control box we have
a register pointing to that and we can
use our 13 for this they will point into
it at a certain point now the thing
about the ARM chip is that to make
interrupts fast it actually has
registers that can overlay other
registers so I'm using R 13 here but
this is the register that exists in
supervisor mode inside the CPU it's not
the same register that we use when we're
writing our code that runs in user mode
we talked about that in another video so
the first thing I'm going to do is store
multiple registers into memory address
pointed to by R 13 and I'm actually
going to take all the registers are 0
through R 14 I'm dumping the registers
into memory so these get written in here
R 0 R 1 and that's just copying the
values in and that's just that's just
normal RAM that's been allocated as part
of the operating system we call in this
bit we've set things up so pointing of
that but we need to be careful because
of the state of our CPU isn't just
stored in the registers that we can
access it's another register the status
register which contains the flags that
decide whether we can branch because if
things have been compared and they're
equal or not equal or less than than
greater than so we also need to store
that the way we do that is we move that
status register into R 0 like so so
we're copying that register into there
and then we can store that
into memory below here so restoring
again relative to our 13 the value of R
0 which is now the value of the status
register so that goes in below where we
were before and also the value in R 14
which because of the way the armpits the
work will be the return address of our
primal way we want to continue running
from so we store that in there what do
we want to do next well next we want to
get the process control block of the
next process we want to do and the way
the arm suggests you do that is that you
load R 13 with the value in memory
pointed to by the register art well
again that would have been set up by
something else and then you add 4 onto
the end so that you then project in the
X process probably want to check here
that you're not pointing at a null
pointer because if you are things would
crash and so if we're not then what we
do is we load multiple registers and
then down dB if not equal to 0 from R 13
which we've now pointed up but remember
we're still pointing at the same thing
actually we're pointing down here now so
we load them back into R 0 and R 14 we
then move back into the status register
that we had before will just simplify
things a bit for the point of this video
the value mu naught so we're setting the
status register back up and then we move
the registers that were are at a loss
are 13 back into R 0 to R 14 but of
course these are the registers from the
other process because we changed here
which process we're pointing at and the
last thing we need to do is we just need
to wait a bit so we will an illustration
which doesn't do anything and we then
set up the program counter so you're
moving to the program counter the value
which we put in our for teens but
because of the way the pipeline works on
the arm CPUs we have to subtract for as
if we execute that block of code we can
preserve the contents of the current
process propping its registers and its
data so that's the important bit and
then loading the value of the previous
programs status register and values so
then
you can just go back to our program and
continue running our scriptures as if
nothing had happened because all the
registers have the same values or the
memory addresses have the same value and
the status register of cause which we
didn't have before also has the same
value now for nutrition like this
preserving the state Reggie wouldn't
have made any difference but if a switch
had happened here after the compare
instruction and if that got corrupted
then the branch wouldn't do as we'd
expect so context switching is
relatively easy to implement you so to
preserve all the registers of one
process and then load back in the
preserved registers for the new process
same thing can be done to start a new
process we just set up a dummy process
control block which contains empty
values for those registers at zero say
and then we can just load it in and move
it from runnable back to running to get
things started so that's the sort of
mechanics about how we save one process
and then moving another one the only
other thing we need to do is decide when
we do this because that's where things
get slightly trickier so we said there's
two places we could do it we could
either do it when an operating system
call is made ie when the user asked the
operating system to do something we
could then make a switch and that's
relatively straightforward the operation
gets to the end of whatever it was it
was doing for the process and it can
then make a context switch so it moves
to the different process so we can just
execute the code like that and do that
and that's fine the other time we can do
it is by using an interrupt and what we
do is we set up the hardware of our
system and this can either be a
dedicated hard piece of hardware
generates this interrupt or the some
CPUs and they able you to do that on the
actual CPU itself to generate an
interrupt it's a regular piece of time
because the circuitry has all got
integrated into the system we set up
that interrupt to happen regularly let's
say every two hundredth of a second and
when that fires we can stop whatever
process is running because we're now in
the operating system code so it can
execute the context switch to stop it
running and then move in to another
process and it will continue it is the
only time you have to be careful is if
you're actually running operating system
code at that point when the interrupts
happen you probably don't want to switch
out in the middle of an operating system
call so probably what you do in that
situation is deferred until the
operating system called finished and
then switch
that point otherwise you get some weird
things happening which you might be
halfway through setting up the network
to listen for something and then you
switch out and things could get slightly
covered so you have to be slightly
careful when you do it what happens when
a program relies on say time or the
clock how does that work I mean is that
something you have to factor into your
code or ah-so so for example if you
wanted to program the same was drawing a
real-time clock on screen how do you
make sure that well this again comes
down to things about scheduling which
we'll look at in another video is that
you probably want certain